Thank you so much for coming in out and
here in my talk. Just so you guys know,
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to briefly
read just the introduction from my
buck,
which I think actually tie us pretty
well into what we're going to be talking
about today and then I'm going to talk
a little bit about as was said before,
why it is so tough to talk about race
and then why don't we kind of have to do
it anyway and then I'm going to open up
for question and answers and hopefully
you will be inspired to ask questions
now that you've learned why we need to be
talking about these things.
Now of course I expect that we will be
kind to each other and respectful of each
other when we ask these questions that
we will be considerate of the feelings of
people here,
especially people who are living with
the realities of racial oppression
everyday and whom this discussion will
always take a little bit more out of.
Okay,
so I'm going to start making
as a black woman, race has always
been a prominent part of my life,
or you have never been able to escape
the fact that I am a black woman in a
white supremacist country. My blackness
is woven into how I dressed each morning,
what bars I feel comfortable going to,
what music I enjoy,
what neighborhoods are hanging out in.
The reality is a phrase have not
always been welcome in my life,
but they have always been there.
When I was a young child,
it was the constant questions of why I
was so dark when my mom was so white.
Was I adopted? Where did I
come from? When I became older,
it was the clothes not cut for my shape
and the snide comments about my hair and
lips and the teen idols that would never,
ever find a girl like me. Beautiful.
Then it was the clerks who would follow
me around the stores and the jobs that
we're hiring until I walked in
the door and then they were not.
It was the boss who's who
told me that I was too loud.
The compliments that my hair,
the comments that my hair was too ethnic
for the office and why even though I
was a valued employee,
I was making so much less money than
other white employees doing the same job.
It is the cops.
I can't make eye contact with the Uber's
that abandoned their pickup driving on
instead of stopping when they
see me when I have my sons.
It was the assumptions that they were
older than they were and that they're
rough.
Housing was too violent.
It was the tears that came
home with when a classmate,
classmate had repeated an
ignorant comment of their parents,
but race has also been countless hours
spent marveling at our history evening
spent dancing and cheering to jazz and
rap and and RMB cookouts with ribs and
potato salad and sweet potato pie.
It has been hands of one
and braiding my hair.
It has been reading the magic of the
words of Toni Morrison, Maya Angelou,
Alice Walker,
and knowing that they are written for
it has been parties filled with Joel,
the frys and Fufu and
Nigerian women wearing sequent
covered get gowns and giant
gala is on their heads.
It has been the nod to the black stranger
walking by that says they see you fam.
It has been pride in Malcolm Martin,
Rosa and Angela.
It has been a room full of the most
uninhibited laughter you've ever heard it.
There's been the touch of my young son
as he lays his hand over mine and says
where the same brown race.
My race has been one of the
most defining forces in my life,
but it is not something I always talked
about. Certainly not in the way I do now.
Like many people, most of my days
were spent just trying to get by.
Life is busy and hard. There are
work and kids and chores and friends.
We spend a lot of time bouncing from
one mini crisis to the next. Yes,
my days. Wage justice,
full of microaggressions,
of the pain of an oppression
of racism as they are now,
but I just had to keep
going on like normal.
It's very hard to survive as a
woman of color in this world,
and I remember saying once that if I
stopped to feel really feel the pain of
racism I encountered, I would start
screaming and I would never stop.
So I did what most of us do.
I tried to make the best of it.
I worked 50% harder than my white
coworkers. I stayed late every day.
I dress like everyday was a job interview.
I was over polite to white people.
I encountered in public. I bend over
backwards to prove that I was not angry,
that I was not a threat.
I laughed off.
Racist jokes is if I
didn't feel the sting,
I told myself that it
would all be worth it.
One day that being a successful
black woman was revolution enough,
but as I got older,
as the successes I had reached
four slowly became a reality.
Something inside of me began to shift.
I would try to make my voice
quieter in meetings and I couldn't.
I would try to laugh off the
racist jokes and I couldn't.
I would try to accept my boss has reasons
for why I could have my promotion but
not my res and I couldn't
and I started talking.
I started to question. It started
to resist. It started to demand.
I wanted to know why it was considered
a bad thing, that I was opinionated.
I wanted to know what exactly it was
about my hair. That was unprofessional.
I wanted to know what exactly it was about
that joke that people found funny and
once I started talking I couldn't stop.
I also started writing.
I shifted my food blog into a mommy
blog and I started seeing all the things
that everybody around me had
always said were too negative,
too abrasive and confrontational or
started writing down my and my heartbreak.
I started writing about my fears
for my community and my family.
I had started to see myself and
once you start to see yourself,
you cannot pretend anymore.
It did not go over well.
My white friends having
grown up in Seattle,
the majority of my friends were white,
some of whom I'd known since high school.
We're not happy with the real me. This
was not the deal. They had struck.
Yes, they would rage over global warming
and yell about Republican Shenanigans,
but they would not say a word about the
racial oppression and brutality facing
people of color in this country.
It's not my place.
They'd explain in f when in frustration,
I'd beg for some comment.
I don't really feel comfortable
and as I looked around my town and I
saw that my neighbors were not really my
neighbors. As I saw that my friends
weren't no longer considered me fun.
I began to yell even louder.
Somebody had to hear me.
Somebody had to care.
I could not be alone
like dialysis.
The old went out and in came the
new suddenly people I had never met.
We're reaching out locally and from all
across the country in person than online,
just to let me know that they had read
my blog post and in reading it they felt
heard. Then online publishers
started reaching out to me,
asking if they could republish my work
and locally isolated and invisible people
of color started reaching out, showing
me that I did have neighbors. After all,
I was talking and writing at
first for my very survival,
not for anybody else's benefit.
Thanks to the power and
freedom of the Internet.
Many other people of color have been
able to speak their truths as well.
We've been able to reach
out across cities, states,
even countries to share
and reaffirm that yes,
what we are experiencing is true,
but the Internet has a very wide audience
and even though we were writing for
ourselves the power of
the herd, anger, fear,
pride and love of countless people of
color could not go unnoticed by white
people, especially those who are
genuinely committed to fighting justice,
injustice.
Well,
some have chosen to
turn away upset at this.
Unplug that this unpleasantness had
invaded their space of cat videos and baby
pictures.
Others drew closer,
realizing that they had been missing
something very important. All along
these last few years,
the rise of voices of color coupled with
the widespread dissemination of video,
proof of brutality and injustice against
people of color has brought the urgency
of racism in America to the forefront
of all of our consciousness.
Race is not something people
can choose to ignore anymore.
Some of us have been speaking all
along and I've not been heard.
Others are trying their
voices for the first time.
These are very scary times for a lot of
people who are just now realizing that
America is not and has never been the
melting pot utopia that their parents and
teachers told them it was
they.
These are very scary times for those who
are just now realizing how justifiably
hurt, angry and terrified so many
people of color have been all along.
These are very stressful times for people
of color who have been fighting and
yelling and trying to protect
themselves from a route,
from a world that doesn't care,
to suddenly be asked by those
who've ignored them for so long.
What has been happening your entire life?
Can you educate me
now that we're all in the room?
How do we start the discussion?
This is not just a gap in experience and
viewpoint. The Grand Canyon is a gap.
This is a chasm you could drop
entire solar systems into,
but no matter how daunting you are here
because you want to hear and you want to
be heard,
you are here because you know that
something is very wrong and you want to
change. We can, we can
find our way to each other.
We can find our way to our truth.
I've seen it happen my life as a
testament to it and it all starts with
conversation.
So I'm going to leave it there.
Didn't quite realize how
long my introduction.
So
I'm here to talk about race and I know
that you're here cause at least perhaps
you might want to hear me talk about race.
Even if you don't want to
talk about race yourself.
I don't like talking about race.
I can't stand it.
I do not enjoy a minute of it.
I would rather be talking
about plenty of other things.
I have to talk about race and I want
to make progress on issues of race.
It's funny that I titled My Book,
So you want to talk about race because
I don't really know a lot of people who
actually wants to talk about race,
but I got to sing so you
have to talk about race.
Sounds a little odd to put on the book.
So why is it so hard?
Race is not a new topic.
This is not very new.
This doesn't seem that obscure.
We have people with different races.
Why can't we talk about it?
Why has this been such a difficult
subject for hundreds of years?
There's a couple of reasons why.
One of the main reasons why is because
we are deliberately denied the tools.
We need to talk about it,
and I say deliberately, I
really firmly believe this.
We must first understand that
race is a system of power.
It is a system designed to benefit
some of the expenses others by sheer
convenience.
When you need to pick a group of people
who can be singled out if they look
different from another group,
that's a pretty easy identifier provided
you are in the group that wins when
you're setting up this system.
One of the reasons why it has been so
lasting is because it is very hard for
black people to no longer be black people
now because this is a system of power
and it is a system of power
that does a lot of harm,
brutal in human harm to a lot of people
and because fundamentally the vast
majority of us do not want to sign on
to systems that brutalize and murder
fellow human beings.
It is very important that we are unable
to accurately describe what is happening
in the system in order for
that system to continue.
I have met a lot of very
committed racists in my life,
but I have yet to actually come
face to face with someone who says,
I want to solely be responsible
for the mass imprisonment, murder,
and terror of people of
color in this country.
Even at that extreme calling it
what it is is very difficult.
The other reason why it is cut,
it's not because everybody's bad
and everyone's trying to lie.
It's because the system needs
us to continue to do nothing.
And in order to do that,
in order to stifle what would be our
outrage at how unjust our system is,
we have to not be able to describe it.
It has to be the vague
nothing that cannot,
you can't make any progress. So often
people come up to me and they say,
it's too big. What can I do? I'm
just one person. It's too much.
You can't change a system
that's been around for so long.
But think of how long you've been told.
You can't change the system without
actually being told what the system is.
It's like Voldemort, like you
just can't say it. If you say it,
then it will be bad. But nobody knows
what it is that they're so afraid of.
Now the good news is,
is the thing that we actually are so
afraid of is an economic, cultural,
and political system,
not that scary. Or we,
the thing we are afraid of is a collection
of decisions we are making every day
where we spend our money,
how we vote,
what we expect from our elected officials,
what we deem as professional or
unprofessional or valued as unvalued.
This collection of every day we
make turns into a system of race.
It upholds a system of race,
but in the end,
even if we don't know why it
is we're participating in,
it has a hefty pay out
for a very select few
and it is in their interest that we
never stopped and question what race
actually is in this country and what
racial oppression is in this country.
So if you don't have the words for it,
think of how often in school
you were given the worst for it.
Even if you did that exercise where like
half your class had blue eyes and half
your class,
you had brown eyes where you've then given
the words to actually talk about race
in your house or with your friends.
Okay,
well you actually given the words beyond
this makes people feel bad as to what
the impact that has on society on,
let's say,
the employment outcomes for
people of color in this country.
Throughout every one of our
efforts to get forward on this,
we kind of stopped with the whole stop
doing mean things to people of color
because it hurts their feelings and then
we wonder why we don't get anywhere.
Which brings me to one of
the other reasons why it's
so hard to talk about race
because we want this
to be about intentions.
We want to be good people and we want to
be seen as good people and we all know
that racism is bad, right? We've
been told this forever and it is.
I'm not here to like shock
you and saying it's good.
That part's true.
There's just a lot more to it.
Our idea of a racist,
right?
As someone who like can't stop
shouting the n word, right?
Or yelling that like Mexicans are coming
to take all your jobs or it's someone
on horseback riding
across and someone's lawn.
These are people with hate in
their hearts who wants to do harm.
Now this stops us from being able to
talk about race because when someone says
you did this thing and it
was racist and it's hurt me,
you don't want to be in that group.
You yourself have never said
the n word in your life.
You are a good person.
You don't want to be a bad person,
but that's not the way race works.
Okay?
The personal outcomes for people of Color
and our society is not built upon how
many racial slurs have been
hurled at them in their lifetime.
It is not.
Black households in this country have
13 times less net worth than white
households because they were called the
n word this many times and every time
their bank account dropped.
That's not how race works.
Furthermore,
there are plenty of people who would
shout racial slurs at me all day and
outside of that moment of terror,
which he does have,
they have no other impact on my life.
There are plenty of people who
dedicate their lives to racism,
who aren't registered to vote, who don't
hold any positions of social power,
who kind of stick around with other
white people who hate people of color and
never leave that weird little hovel.
They are impacting me nearly as much
as someone who has a black lives matter
poster in their window,
but then votes for tighter
policing because she's a
little scared about the way
the demographics of her
neighborhood is changing.
Okay?
Right. When it comes to my
safety and my ability to live,
she is making a much bigger
negative impact on my life
and the life of my family
and the wife of my friends.
And that's where we have to realize.
But in a system that only requires that
you do nothing in order to continue to
perpetrate itself,
your intentions don't mean squat.
Yeah.
So if you did not mean to harm someone,
it does not mean that
the harm wasn't done.
And it does not mean that you then
hate them and you must be discarded.
But it also doesn't mean that they must
immediately forgive you and act like it
never happened.
But it's very hard to talk about race
when we can't update their ideas of what
racial oppression actually looks like
and what racism looks like when it hits
people of color.
One second.
It's also really tough to talk about
because we never actually say what we're
trying to talk about.
What we're doing when we're talking about
race usually is we have people who are
trying to come to their own personal
goals and usually people of color come in
and talk about race,
are trying to get other people to
understand what is harming them.
And very often white people come to rate,
come to talks about race to try and
make sure the person they're talking to
knows that they are not the
person who is harming them.
Those are two completely
different conversations that
we'll never meet because
you have one person
who's lived experiences,
you are harming me and
I need you to understand
and you have another person
she was lived experience says,
I am not part of the problem. I am a
good person. And I need you to understand
because don't state what it is
that we're trying to talk
about when we talk about race,
you can dissolve an entire
friendship in a discussion.
And if you were to ask why
of each person in that discussion,
the reasons would be completely different.
So we know what it is.
Tough.
We know there's a lot at risk and if
you are a white person in this room and
most of you are,
and you're thinking,
what if I get called racist?
Oh,
last time I tried a couple of times
it ended really bad. Trust me.
No conversation on racist
ever ended nearly as bad for
you as an ends for people
of color. So before we launch
into why we have to do it anyways,
I want to first say if a person of color
is willing to talk to you about race,
even if they don't seem very friendly
while they're doing it, it's a generosity.
I asked a lot of my friends
when I was working on my book,
what are your greatest fears
about talking about race?
And a lot of white people
were like, oh, you know,
I'm just afraid of being seen as
racist. You know, I'm really afraid.
Um, you know that like I'll get
dragged on black Twitter. Um,
and then my friends of color were like,
I'm afraid I'm going to
get fired from my job.
I'm afraid I will be physically attacked.
I'm afraid it will be harassed.
And there were plenty of people who said,
I have been harassed.
I currently have a restraining order
out on someone who I said was racist and
then tried to ruin my entire life.
I have people of color who have actual
threats to their life and liberty and
their ability to feed their families.
And then you have white people who are
afraid that they will be called racist.
So know when people of color come
to these discussions, first off,
they're already bringing their pain
pain that you do not know the bringing a
damage that has already been done.
And they're bringing a team knowing
that there's probably a 90% chance this
conversation isn't gonna go well
yeah,
that they're going to lose out. They're
going to be seen as angry. At best,
there'll be dismissed as you know,
overly rakes focused
and that they will lose
steam for you,
which hurts them.
They may lose a friend in the process
of just trying desperately to get you to
see their humanity.
So think about how generous it is to
have a life time of experience that says
this is not gonna end well
for you and you do it anyway.
And then wonder,
should you really be that afraid
to join them to meet them halfway.
Should you really be that afraid to talk
to your uncle at the dinner table when
he says something a bit off?
It's something we have to talk.
So why is it something we have
to talk about? First of all,
we're always talking about it and I
think that this is something that people
always forget.
We live in a society with a white default,
okay?
Everything is whiteness or holidays.
Okay?
Our calendar,
what we view as professional
or films or books,
the art that we call fine art versus
the art that we call ethnic art.
We live in a world defined by whiteness.
One of,
I understand a lot about white people.
I grew up here in Seattle and
that was raised by a white mother,
but I will never know what it's like to
be able to walk around in a world built
for me.
I never have to say it was built for me
to never have to recognize white culture
is white culture.
I always have to recognize black culture
is black culture because even if I'm
going about my day and my blackness,
someone's going to make it a parent.
I am doing something that is outside
of the norm. Walking around in my hair.
People make it very apparent,
whether it's weird comments about how
glad they are that I've embraced who I am
or the comments about how it's
a little wall. That's wild.
That's funky. I like it. It's
not wild are funky. It's,
it's the hair that grows out of my head.
Hmm.
I don't walk up to everyone who gets out
of the shower comes to work and go wild.
Funky. It's kind of stringy. I,
we live in a culture defined by whiteness,
which means,
but anytime you're not talking about race,
you're talking about whiteness.
What you're basically saying is everything
is white until I deem it otherwise.
And you're saying here, people
of Color, you navigate that.
You navigate this culture 24 hours a day
until I am comfortable enough to ask if
maybe it doesn't always suit you.
Maybe I'm deemed to be the one to
step around and try a different path.
We like to act as if it's people of color,
always bringing up race.
Yeah.
But if I go for a job interview and the
way that my hair grows out of my head is
not deemed a professional,
I am not making it about race.
I'm the one who,
because those doing the interview didn't
stop to think about their definition
and whether or not it included
everyone who might show up for a job,
who has to figure out what professional
means to white people and then has to go
and modify the hair that grows out
of my head in a way to fit that.
I don't want to make it about race.
I would like to just show up in
the hair that grows out of my head.
I didn't make it about race and me saying,
Hey,
I should be able to show him up with
the hair that comes out of my head.
It's my attempt to no longer make it
about race to no longer make it about
whiteness. So often these issues
that you find yourself saying,
why does it always have to be about race?
It's because it was about race when you
decided that the only people who needed
to be considered where white,
that's what made it about race.
Now oftentimes people of color are trying
to get it back to a place where it's
not.
We have to talk about it because right
now we are all harming other people
because we have spent a lifetime absorbing
incredibly harmful messaging about
people of different races,
about people of color.
That means I have spent a lifetime
absorbing harmful messaging about Asian
Americans, about indigenous
people, about Latinex Americans,
and about black Americans.
It means everyone here has,
and when you see something and it hits
a person of color and they know deep
inside that that's not right,
but they're not comfortable telling you
you are missing the opportunity to become
a better person and it stopped hurting
people.
If you don't want to talk about it,
what you're saying is you just continue
to carry that hurt and the next person
after you should continue
to carry that hurt.
Because the thought of carrying my piece
of it and doing the work necessary to
stop,
it's just a little too much.
I would rather continue the blissful
ignorance of doing harm and having other
people pick up the mess.
I don't think that's the type
of person you want to be.
I myself personally in my work have to
constantly challenge that because even as
a black woman,
there is a lot of messaging
I have absorbed about
people of color have that in
my work requires me to face and
recognize where I may have harmed people.
Yeah.
And try to make amends because as much
as it stings to know I've heard someone I
would rather know.
So I can do better,
but continue to think I'm
the thing since slice bread,
while I'm hurting everyone in my path,
we have to talk about race because it's
the only way to identify solutions.
What we're talking about here is not just
big group therapy or we're crying and
hugging our way out of this.
I honestly don't believe that will work
and I really don't want people to hug me.
I I'm talking about identifying where we
are missing opportunities to be a part
of the solution and that actually means
you have to talk to the people and find
out where the problem is.
And we miss a lot of opportunities.
You think of the last time a friend of
yours made a joke that just wasn't cool
and you decided to let it go.
Now if you are a white
person and you hear a joke,
it's not cool and you decide to let
it go cause you don't want to ruin the
evening,
think about who never gets the
opportunity to make that choice.
I don't get the opportunity.
My evenings ruined.
I don't even like if there's no saving it.
Like my evenings ruined.
My relationship with that
person is forever altered.
I don't get a chance to say I'm going
to not be black for the evening and not
have that hurt me.
I don't get to say I'm going to wait
until next month and then maybe I'll bring
it up. If they, you know, make a joke
at the expense of my humanity gun,
then I'll bring it up no
matter what I'm harmed.
Okay.
We have to talk about it.
Yeah.
Because what we are doing not only causes
hurt feelings not only causes trauma,
but it has actual measurable impacts
in the wellbeing for people of color in
this country.
So if you don't understand,
okay,
what the school to prison pipeline looks
like and you haven't heard for mothers
of black children whose kindergartners
have been dragged out of their classrooms
by school,
please officers,
but you will not make an informed voting
choice when it comes to your local
school board. Chances are you
probably won't even vote for it if it,
especially if it's an off year
and you're going to leave that 10% of
the population most at risk to fight that
battle on their own and then you'll
wonder as your kid gets older,
why these black kids can't
just get it together.
Why are they always getting suspended?
Why are they always getting expelled
and you'll think it's their problem.
When you had an opportunity for years
earlier to put in school board members who
could say,
we're going to take a look at the way
in which we are disciplining children of
color to see if it's fair to see if it's
in the best interest of these children.
If you don't talk to people of color
about how hard it is for them to access
resource access resources
in their neighborhood,
how you vote for taxes and levies in
your city and state that could give money
to neighborhoods that don't even have
working sidewalks and we do have stretches
here in the Seattle area,
but I don't have working sidewalks.
Kids are walking to
school on busy highways,
then you're not going to vote
accordingly because your street's fine,
but you didn't want to talk about
race and why money has kept from these
neighborhoods.
Why so much of it's about how wealthy
the tax bracket is for that neighborhood
and then you wonder why people aren't
rising up when they can't even get to
school safely, when they can't have
updated books in their classrooms,
when the nearest grocery store that would
give them the nutrition they need to
be able to pay attention through the day
is a mile and a half away and there's
no rule,
good bus routes,
but we're going to keep voting
to lower our tabs, right?
Without looking at the impact that
has and the people who need reliable,
low cost transportation more than
anyone else. These are conversations,
these are so blue oceans you come
to you when you talk about race,
but they are also solutions you are
rejecting when you don't talk about race.
It is not just something from
the heaven comes down and says,
would you like a bonus
solution for race today?
And you accepted and
you're glad for this extra.
These are responsibilities
that you're abdicating,
but no one else will pick up.
These are opportunities that you
are morally obligated to take,
that you are denying because you
don't want to have an uncomfortable
conversation.
Now.
It's not as easy and please for the
love of God, do not rush out of here.
Find the nearest black person
in the office and be like, Hey,
let's have a conversation about race.
Please.
There's a reason why there's
a lot of chapters from my book
because we have to do this in a way
that is not putting in an even more of a
burden, a marginalized people, but
it definitely can be done in first.
I would say start googling Google.
Oh my gosh,
you guys right?
Start googling.
There's not a question you
have that hasn't been asked.
There's not a sticky situation you are in,
has it you have that
someone else hasn't been in
before you stop and say,
I'm going to go and talk to Lataetia and
she's going to be my new dictionary of
race relations.
Google it.
Figure out what you're talking about.
Read My,
get some pointers and then start looking
in everyday opportunities to have
conversations, not just with people
of a different race than you,
but people in your own race. Especially
if you're white in this audience.
Please start talking to other white
people about this because it was only like
five black people in this entire city.
Like we can't have all these conversations
and make sure that you're talking
to people love multiple races.
I speak as a black woman.
I write as a black woman.
My experience in this world though, is
not the same as it is for a Latinex woman,
right? Or an Asian American
men, and you can't say,
I talked to a black person.
They're cool with it. We're fine,
but
come to it.
Knowing that as hard as it is,
it's always going to give
you an opportunity to be a
better person and to make a
difference in this world.
And that should excite you because for
the first time you may actually see and
the ability to make progress where you've
been told forever that you couldn't,
that there were just some people that
were always going to hate and some people
like you that we're going to laugh and
maybe one day love would win and then you
wonder why things aren't getting better.
You will have actual measurable
things you can do to make it better.
But it starts with conversation.
So that's kind of my talk and now,
yeah, he's walking around. So I think,
yeah, I hope there will be questions.
So, uh, I decided I want him to
come to a talk that was called,
so you want to talk about race? Um,
I was kind of sold already on that.
That seems like a good idea.
Um,
one of my main takeaways was that if I
end up talking about race with somebody
who is not white,
that they will have a bad time.
How do you reconcile those?
I mean that's the thing is it's,
it's almost,
I've never left a conversation about race,
especially with someone of a different
race and been like, man, that was fun.
Um,
I want you to come to that knowing her,
the reason why people engage with it
is because that's how urgent it is.
So there are things you want to do,
there are things you need to do. No,
that means that there were going to be
times where even as painful as it is,
I am dying to talk about race because
I know this only thing that's going to
make this situation better or are the
only thing that's going to make it seem
like I'm not completely invisible
to the people around me.
It's like you're walking around in,
your world is on fire and
people are literally going,
God I am so
cool
and like putting on Parker's and you're
dying and you're like, what are you,
what are you doing? No, you don't want
to talk about what that feels like.
You don't want to be like,
let me explain to you for an hour what
it's like to be this hot. But sometimes,
you know,
if I don't get someone to ask,
why are you so wow right now,
I'm going to actually die.
And that's oftentimes what
talking about racist. No,
it doesn't mean that it won't be rewarding
in the end, even if it's not pleasant.
Because I do think when these do go
well in the more of these that do,
it will shift.
Part of the reason why it's not pleasant,
it's because most of the
time it goes really bad.
And so we're already entering
in talking about pay.
We're going through knowing that chances
are all of that investment isn't going
to pay off.
So part of it is it's committing to be
someone who it might pay off, you know,
be like, Hey, you know what?
I'm going to try my best to be a little
different and listen and hear and be
here.
All right?
So how do I present as someone who
is less likely to cause somebody I'm
having a conversation with to have a bad
time, uh, without, uh,
like giving everyone a
minority tax, everybody like,
Hey, you're a black person.
Yeah. You know, I would
definitely say first off,
always try and gauge people's comfort
level in a conversation. Right?
So people of course,
especially because of the work,
I do want to talk to me about race a
lot and in fact sometimes people come to
save the conversations. They've been
afraid to happen to anyone else for me.
But when people gauge my comfort
level, say, hey, you know,
I had a question about something with
race or I was wondering if maybe this was
something you wanted to talk about. Are
you comfortable? Is this a good time?
If not,
I fully understand start back way.
Because a lot of times what happens is
people get really eager and I think I'm
going to make a person of color day today.
I'm going to go up to him and
start asking them about race.
And that's just not
the way to go about it.
But it happens more than you than
you would assume and instead saying,
are you comfortable? Do you feel safe? Do
you want her to have this conversation?
Oftentimes even that alone,
like knowing that someone took the time
to even wonder if I want to have that
conversation is a good sign to me it's
going to go better cause it's already
starting with listening.
It's already starting with
consideration for me as a human,
so I definitely started there.
I then always take time to pause and make
sure you're listening more than you're
talking and that you're stating your
intentions and that you're checking in and
looking for signals that someone is
still comfortable if they're not say,
I am sorry,
I didn't mean to make you uncomfortable.
We can totally pause or a B out
of this conversation entirely,
but a lot of times what ends up happening
is you'll start a conversation and
it'll veer into areas that are no longer
safe and comfortable for people of
color and then it becomes, well what?
I thought you wanted to end racism,
why aren't you still talking to me about
it? But the truth is, is, you know,
this'll be the 20th conversation
I'm going to have today.
I need to be willing to like reserve
what I have left and move on.
Um,
so I would say definitely starting with
finding your comfort level if they want
to talk about it or not,
and stealing why it is you want to talk
about it are going to get you probably
at least halfway there
to having a conversation.
It's going to be one of the ones that
actually surprises people of coming by
going pretty well. Your parents, um,
parents and um, unfortunately grew
up in a household where I'm raised,
was brought up.
It was always negative and I knew when
I had my children and even just finding
out that that wasn't the type of
household I wanted to have. Um,
I want to know when I can be
doing to be a better parent,
to be teaching my kids how
to have these conversations,
how to be better people
as far as you know,
how they're treating their friends and
the people that they encounter every day
properly. It's a great question. I'm
assuming you have wakids. Yep. Okay. Um,
what I would definitely say,
um,
and I refer to those quite often cause
I think it's a really good example.
I was actually talking with
an associate a while back.
He was asking me about what it was like.
This was a white man.
He was asking me what it was like to
have to explain to my kids about avoiding
cops in what police brutality is and
like why store clerks might follow them
around things like this.
And he said,
I'm so glad I don't have to have
that conversation with my kids.
And they pass. And I was like, oh,
why don't you have to have
the conversation with your
kids? It's like, well,
you know what I mean? I'm
like, no, no, I really don't.
Because you're grateful that your kids
had been spared this painful conversation,
but your kids are in
community with my kids.
Why would your kids be
spared this conversation?
Why would they be spared the knowledge
of what their friends are dealing with?
Why would they be spared the
opportunity to lift that burden?
At least some of it,
but showing at least they understand.
It's really important to realize your
kids are going to be absorbing what's
happening in the world no matter what.
And you have to provide context and you
have to provide empowerment and places
of action.
So I like personally,
I have of course to kids of color and
so I talk with them oftentimes to see
outside their own experience
to other kids of color,
maybe kids of different races.
What I like to do,
especially when we're like listening to
the news and you hear all these awful
things happening and kids
really feel powerless.
They feel like grownups are
kind of screwing everything
up for them and they are,
and there's nothing they can do about it.
So I always like to talk with my kids
about solutions that they can help be a
part of. Right? They have no power is
to who's president and this country,
but they have a lot of power as to what
their friends at school are sitting to
other kids at school.
Right?
They have the power to raise their
hands and the teacher and say, Hey,
I don't think that's right.
So we'd like to like listen to the
news and especially, you know my,
well both my teenagers kind of like, he
thinks he's got it all figured out, right?
So I don't know.
He's absorbing probably half of it.
I talked non stop and said Mama, no
ignoring them. I have the Internet. Um,
my 10 year old.
On the other hand,
it's incredibly passionately concerned
about what's happening. Right?
He's very concerned about immigration,
very, very concerned about immigration.
He has friends who come home,
whose parents have told them they might
have to go away one day. Right? He's very,
very concerned about transgender rights.
And so these are things where instead
of saying, yeah, man, it sucks,
the world is horrible because you grow
up being an adult that just says that
instead, I think, okay,
well you know what?
Chances are right now you have kids in
your class who are worried about where
their parents are going to be.
So are you talking with your friends about
this issue and letting them know that
you support them?
Are you listening for kids who might be
saying hateful things that their parents
are saying and challenging?
That's right.
You have kids in your class who may
one day come out as transgender.
So are you making sure that no one is
saying anything that would harm them right
now? Are you talking to your
teachers about the bathrooms?
Maybe there's something that can be
done about your school bathrooms, right?
Giving them the opportunity
to know there's always a
way to be reaching out and
finding solutions even in
their own little corner.
And that not only is going to keep them
being solution oriented and reaching out
and working out,
but it's also going to keep them feeling
empowered so they don't enter adulthood,
jaded and feeling it. There's
nothing they can do about it. Lou,
I uh, actually have the privilege
of having the last question,
just Fyi. Um, uh, first of all, thank
you so much for putting on this talk.
You are wonderful writer and speaker
as well, so thank you very much.
I wanted to ask,
um,
if you have any advice for someone who is,
uh,
a person of color black specifically
who is navigating a white workplace?
Um,
I have worked at Google for
about a year and a half and um,
I didn't know that I was willing going
to be like the only black female engineer
here. Um, and that's, you know,
it's cool but sometimes I wish I wasn't.
Um,
do you have any advice for like feeling
kind of alone and feeling like you want
to be with people who look like you?
I understand that feeling.
Before I was a writer actually
worked in tech for a decade and um,
I was always the only black person
except for once I had a black supervisor.
Um,
I know that family and it's a very lonely
place to be and unfortunately because
of the way the world is,
the more you rise up,
the more lonely you end up and first off,
that's a completely normal way to feel
it. Definitely. Um, I would say two fold.
One, personally, you have to find
community even if it's not in work.
And I know it's hard because we
spent so much time at work in,
especially in fields like this,
but you've got to find community,
you've got to find people.
There aren't groups of black
people in the greater area,
especially tech focus, black people
that kind of of seek each other out.
So definitely, you know, hit me up after
this if you have any questions on that.
Um, so definitely do that.
But then also I would say
always know it's going to be harder to
change the rules of how people engage
with you and later than
it is to set it up front.
And that's something I started learning
about halfway through my tech career
when I was in tech was there were,
there are a lot of compromises we
find ourselves having to make things.
We don't talk about things
we don't address. Right. In
order to get where we are.
What I realized was the further I got,
the harder it was to go back and correct.
And so I had the always
weigh in smart ways, right?
To not get my house flyer,
how to challenge things so that people
knew from the moment they started doing
business with me, but I was going
to be challenging these assumptions.
So I started with a lot of
innocent questions. Right.
My favorite thing to do would be w w
what do you mean? What does that mean?
I don't,
I'm sorry I didn't,
I just don't understand and I'm not
trying to be like, no, what do you mean?
I'm like, no, I don't. I'm good. I don't
get what? What does that mean? I don't,
what's funny about that thing?
You know,
I always like to point out those little
things just to be like, not like,
you know, we're kind of have
a discussion about this,
but like there was this thing,
it works that used to drive me bonkers
is actually still happens to me.
Even as a writer online where it's say
I'm hungry and someone would say, well,
we try and give me cheese all the
time. People will be like, Jeez,
I don't know what it is about
selling cheese. Oh, it's this,
this is like a Swedish thing. No people
like all man, go get you some cheese.
And I'm like, I hope you understand the
majority of black people or electrical.
Sometimes I'm like,
are you trying to not only ruin my day
but your day because you have to sit next
to you? And it wasn't like,
how dare you not know this?
It was just like,
hey,
you know where it say,
yeah,
no cheese isn't going to work
for me because I'm black.
Sometimes I leave it at that
because then people will be like,
what do you mean? And think a little
bit, is there something like, yeah, no,
it's magic. She is mortal enemy. Like no,
actually the majority of people of color,
not just black people, Asian people,
indigenous people.
We don't do cheese too well and like
get people starting to think and I would
start to challenge a lot of those things.
You know,
we would have get together
work and be like, Hey,
did you know that's not necessarily um,
that cool dive bar.
You think it would be fun?
The slum in with the confederate flag
can in the corner and not necessarily a
place where I'm going to be safe
and I would just constantly,
and like a very even
keel say these things.
And I learned that when people started
to figure out that I was never actually
going to let those things go,
but it wasn't going to turn into a fight.
Sometimes it was just like,
well, it's less knowing.
I actually start thinking about these
things ahead of time and start really
addressing them. But I would definitely
say find community. Um, learn.
You know,
what compromises you are and are not
willing to make early and think if I make
it all the way to VP, do I still
want to be ignoring these jokes?
Do I still want to be having
these horrible conversations?
Do I still want to be acting like
my needs are being met with or not?
Because believe it or not,
it's actually harder when you get to
that level to have those conversations.
And now I hope that helps.
I mean,
unfortunately you shouldn't have to
be asking these questions. Absolutely.
And hopefully people listening in this
room will help make it so that that won't
be a case.
Right.
I mostly asked this question for
their benefit, not mine. Yeah.
I like the way you think.
Thank you very much for
coming to talk to us today.
[inaudible].